من الخرطوم محمد المختار النور المستشار
القانوني للدعم السريع من الخرطوم ايضا
الامين داوود القيادي بالحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه ورئيس الجبهه الشعبيه
المتحده للعداله ابدى معك سيد محمد
المختار النور المستشار القانوني للدعم
السريع كنا نحاول التواصل معك قبل قليل
الاصلاح ما يجري في ام درمان والمواقع
التي اعلنتم الانسحاب التكتيكي منها على
واقع الضربات بطائرات الجيش
مرحبا بك ومرحبا بضيفك الكريم لازال
القوات الدعم السريع هي مسيطره على المشهد
على الارض وسيطرت على عدد كبير جدا من
المواقع من ضمنها القياده العامه وعدد
المقر الاستراتيجيه وكذلك حتى الان مسيطره
على بعض المناطق درمان وكذلك مسيطره على
المناطق جنوب الخرطوم بالكامل وكذلك
مسيطره على اقليم دارفور بالكامل وسيطر
على كردفان والقوات الان مسيطر على مطار
مروي وتجري الان عمليات تمشيط لبقيه
المناطق المناطق ان شاء الله
مدى دقه يعني هذه
الاخبار المتعلقه بالسيطره حول
القياده العامه بحكم وجود الاشتباكات حتى
اللحظه
الان كانت الاشتباكات اليوم منذ حجر اليوم
في داخل القياده العامه
واستطاعت القوات تستولى على برج القوات
البريه والبحريه وبعض
الداخل
ما الذي ما الذي تنوي فعله قوات الدعم
السريع في الفتره
المقبله بالنظر الى تدخل سلاح الجو وقصف
عدد من المواقع التي اعلنتم بالفعل
الانسحاب منها
سلاحك هو الان القوات تستطيع ان تتعامل
معه واستطاعت ان تسقط عدد من الطائرات في
قاعده جري وفي بعض المناطق تم استخدام
سلاح الجوفيه والان القوات في عهده
الاستعداد للتعامل مع اي طارئ متعلق بسلاح
الجو
يعني ما هو نوع التعامل هنالك مواقع يعني
يجري تسليمها او يجري السيطره عليها من
الجيش هل ما زالت يعني الخطه من اللحظه
الاولى كما اعلنها حمايه السيطره على كل
المواقع
نعم الخطه هي السيطره على كل المواقع بعد
الهجوم من قبل الجيش على مناطق الدعم
السريع فاستطاعت الدعم السريع ان تدحر
القوات واستطاعه ان تفصل سيطرتها الى عدد
كبير جدا من المقام والمواقع والحمد لله
الان الاوضاع يعني ماشيه على الهدئه ونبشر
الشعب السوداني ان الوضع ان شاء الله سوف
يمثل بعض اللحظات ان شاء الله الى استخراج
جزء هنا الحرب طبعا هي
الاوضاع ان شاء الله صحيح
سيطرت الدعم السريع على القياده العامه
تمشيط القياده العام ما الذي تتوقعه من
مدى هذه المعركه الى متى ستستمر
بالتاكيد لا استطيع ان المعركه تنتهي متى
لكن الان في تقدم كبير جدا والدعم السريع
تقدمت في مساحات في وسط الخرطوم
90% منها الان تحت سيطرتها والان المتبقي
العشره في الميه ان شاء الله
في اللحظات القادمه ما مدى تاثير الضربات
ضربات السلاح الجو على مقراتكم هنالك اكثر
من اعلان عن تدمير لهذه المقرات بشكل كامل
لا لا يوجد تدمير للمقرات بشكل كامل يمكن
ان الطيران ان يضرب ولكن لا استطيع ان دم
التدمير كامل بالتاكيد لانه المعاطي هي
كلها مناطق يعني ماهوله بالسكان وكذلك
المناطق المتواجد في هذه القوات هي مدينه
الخرطوم وبالتالي الطيران فاعليته ضعيفه
في المناطق المختلظه باللباني وغيره وعند
مستشار قانوني الا يجعل يعني ذلك او يسبب
لكم حرجا ووجودكم داخل المناطق التي تحظى
بكثافه السكانيه وبالتالي تعرض حياه الناس
والسكان الى الى الخطوره
السكان القياده العامه في قلب الخرطوم وده
وضع الطبيعي انه الحرب في وسط الخرطوم
وهذا الامراض الجيش
ان تمشي الامور في اتجاه التهدئه واتجاه
التسويه السياسيه اللي كانت
قوات الجيشيه بادره الهجوم على قوات الدعم
السريع في منطقه اللي هي في قلب الخرطوم
وبالتالي كنا مجبرين على الرد على هذه
الاعتداءات وهذا يعني مفروضه علينا ان
نخوض
هنالك اختلاف في موازين القوى بينكم بين
الجيش بحكم امتلاك الجيش على معدات كبيره
مثل الدبابات والطائرات
وغيرها هل تعولون على بقائكم في هذه
المناطق التي وصفتها الماهوله بالسكان
بهذه السيارات سيارات الدفع الرباعي
تقاومون هذا هذا المد الكبير من الجيش
السريع كذلك امتلك دبابات وكذلك في بعض
المعارك امتلك الان اكثر من 200 دبابه
والان هذه الدبابات كلها تخوض معارك مع
الدعم السريع
وتم طبعا يعني التعامل مع بقيه الدبابات
التي لم يتم
استلاء عليها وتم تدميرها والان والدعم
من الدباباتي هل هل للقوات قوات الدعم
السريع النيه في ان تفتح جبهات خارج
الخرطوم في دارفور وفي يعني في الشمال
الان الان في دارفور كل دارفور يعني تحت
سيطره قوات الدعم السريع وعدد من الولايات
كردفان تحت سيطره في الدعم السريع وكذلك
منطقه مروي تحت سيطره الدعم السريع وبعض
المناطق في وسط الخرطوم كلها تحتفظ الدعم
السريع طيب انت مستشار قانون ربما استمعت
الى اعلان الجيش بان قوات الدعم السريع
اصبحت الان ميليشيا متمرده
يرفض الجيش اي تفاوض قبل حل هذه
الميليشيات ما يعني موقفه بالتوصيف الجديد
هذا كلام غير صحيح وغير منطقي قوات الدعم
الفريق قوات المنشاه بموجب قانون في عام
2017 وهذا القانون اجازه البرلمان فمثله
مثل قانون قوات الشعب المسلح الذي اجازه
نصف البرلمان البرلمان منتخب وما انشئ
بقانون اخي الكريم لا يلغى الا بموجب
قانون هذا الوضع الطبيعي لهذه القوات
فبالتالي التحديد عن انها ميليشيات هذا
مجافي للحقيقه ومجافي هذه القوات كانت
تعمل جنبا على جمع القوات المسلحه المعركه
وكانت تدافع عن الوطن وتزود عن حماه
الوطن وكذلك تقوم بادوارها الامنيه
فالحقيقه ان حلقات الدعم السريع هذه الصفه
يملكها البرلمان والبرلمان الان في الوضع
الحالي لا يوجد برلمان فبالتالي تزلق
الدعم السريع موجوده بقانونها الى حين ان
ياتي برلمان منتخب من الشعب السوداني بين
البرلمان الاول الذي اقر بالقانون وضعيه
هذه
القوات وبين البرلمان المنتظر هنالك هنالك
فقط اذا سمحت من السؤال
هنالك فتره انتقاليه هنالك مجلس سيادي
يرسه البرهان نائمه فيه محمد حمدان حماتي
اذا كان قائد الجيش اعلن هذه القوات
ميليشيا متمرده فما هو موقف حمايه نفسه
والدعم السريع من الجيش هل هو يعتبر نفسه
الان عضو مجلس السياده ونائب للبرهان
حتى الان لا توجد اي قرارات قدرت الغاء
القرارات الاولى المتعلقه بمجلس السياده
هذا قرار لشخص لا يملك هذا القرار وله
الحق في هذا
قيمه قانونيه دستوريه
هنالك فتره انتقاليه هذه الفتره
الانتقاليه تليها انتخابات وبعض
الانتخابات ان شاء الله تجد حكومه
الوضعيه القانونيه الدعم السريع وبقيه
القوات الاخرى فقط لان الصوت كان يتقطع
نريد اجابه اوضح هل يعتبر السيد محمد
حمدان حمايه نفسه الان عضوا في مجلس
السياده او نائبا للبرهان في رئاسه مجلس
السياده
نعم الان هو نائبا للبرهان بحكم الوضع
القانوني الموجود فيه وكذلك قائد لقوات
الدعم السريعه
بالنسبه
للتطورات المعركه نائب مجلس السياده يشن
حربا ويعلنوا رئيس مجلس السياده يعني عدوا
في هذه المرحله هل هذا وضع قانوني
النائب رئيس الحرف هو في نفسه تمت من
الحرب عليه وهو دافع عن نفسه ودافع عن
موقفه في اتجاه عمليه التحول الديمقراطي
انا لا اتحدث من بدا يعني سؤال من بدا
المعركه يعني ليس هذا هو انا فقط وجهت
لانني لانك من من الدعم السريع كمستشار
قانوني احاول فقط ان اضع السؤال لك وانت
لك حريه الاجابه لكنني لا اقر ولا يعني
احدد من من بدا هذه المعركه عذرا
شكرا شكرا جزيلا
اعيد السؤال مره اخرى يعني بهذه الوضعيه
اذا كان بدا او لم يبدا يشن نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده حربا ويعلن انه سيسيطر على
هذه المقرات لن تنتهي هذه الجوله الا
بالسيطره هكذا اعلن وربما تفضي الى سلام
السيطره على المقرات هل هذا وضع طبيعي
بحكمه وجوده في مجلس السياده كنائب
للبرهان وضع طبيعي عندما يتعنت راس الدوله
وينفرد بالغرار وينفرد بالوضع السياسي في
البلد
وما يلتزم بالمواسير والمعاهدات التي
التزم بها والاتصالات التزم بهذا وضع
الطبيعي يمكن ان نجر البلاد الى حرفها وما
جر البلاد الى حرف وهذه الحرب يمكن ان
تنتهي الى سلام ويمكن ان تنتهي الى الى اي
وضع اخر وفقا الامور فيها فهذا هو المشهد
الماثل على العالم سؤال الاخير فقط السيد
محمد المختار النور الاطراف اطراف عده
بالحقيقه تحدثت عن صعوبه في التواصل معكم
او حتى مع قياده الجيش من اجل تقديم او
تقريب وجهات النظر هل انتم منفتحون او
تتلقون اتصالات وساطه
نعم هنالك بعض الاتصالات
القوات وقياده الجيش وهذا
يعني
معركه حقيقيه ولكن تغليف صوت العقل
والحكمه يعني مطلوب من الاطراف كلها ولكن
هذه المبادرات الان لم تطرح بشكل جدي ولم
يحدد لها اي اطار زمني فبالتالي الحديث
عنها في الوقت الحالي ابتكر ليس له اي
يعني مساحه بحكم الظروف الان اللي بتمر
بها
قطع الاتصال يبدو مع السيد محمد المختار
النور المستشار القانوني للدعم السريع من
الخرطوم شكرا لك على هذه المشاركه